[Music]
[Music]
well navigate guru is set up in 1986 by
a local Suffolk man dick Burge under a
new management team although still
including dick birch our original
founder we've decided that we'd like to
move back to our home in Suffolk and so
navigate breweries in the process of
building a new site in what was once rob
bridge car center I have to say like
most people I think when when I
approached Weber amid Suffolk council to
see how they could help us choose a new
site I was expecting very little support
and how surprised and delighted have
been with the team from the very first
instance when they gave us some really
comprehensive advice on what we would
require from a planning and licensing
perspective the whole team has been
enormous ly supportive and engaged
primarily through the business
development team first of all David
Benham and more luckily Lee Carville
have introduced is to lots of other
support I think the approach can be
summed up by the word helpful I don't
know how their processes work their
seamless from the outside but certainly
when you needed some advice Lee Carville
in particular but also Clare free would
point us in the right direction and open
the door to the specialist advice that
we required they were absolutely pivotal
in in terms of the very selection of the
site the council were helpful in terms
of pointing out where drainage
facilities existed every engagement with
the council their expertise and advice
was invaluable well I don't think we
could have done it without them what I'd
like to say to Bayboro mid Suffolk
council is keep it up we came into this
project expecting the council to
providers only with a string of jobs
Worth and prevarication instead of which
we got enormous support from every
department within the county
centered around Li Kabul whoo-hoo I
can't thank enough for the way in which
he's approached this project almost as
if it was his brewery
[Music]